me doing what i want to do every day
means i'm doing plenty of things every
day i don't want to be doing in the
micro right there's a the next meeting
the this this fire but in the macro i'm
playing the game i'm the captain of this
ship and on sunny days i get to enjoy it
and when the storm hits and our boat
might tip over i've got to have my hands
on the wheel and i've got to fix it
that's where i want to be forever
gary this is such a joy to do as i said
to you beforehand uh seven years of me
uh waiting but i'm so thrilled that you
joined me so thank you so much for
joining me today
thanks for having me harry glad to be on
the show
laura too i would love to start before
we dive into the real me just set some
context how did you make your way into
the world of investing and tack first
before we dive into the meat
you know i never knew about investing i
you know i was when did i invest in
twitter 2007.
um i was 32 years old the first time i
made an investment i had never really
even heard about angel investing the
world was very different back in 2006
now it is common practice most kids
think about being an investor you have
13 year olds you know on robin hood and
nfts and so
i was 32
i never thought about it prior but i got
into social media web 2.0 and i started
go to things like
south by southwest and this and that i
didn't have a lot of money um because i
was working in my dad's liquor store not
getting paid a lot and all the you know
the stories i talk about of like
building a big business but not getting
a lot of dollars so i didn't have a lot
of money so when i first heard like they
put a hundred thousand into this this
guy put a million i was like i don't
that's not for me i don't have that kind
of money then i started realizing like
oh you could write a 25 000 check this
out the other thing and then one thing
led to another and i became very
friendly with
you know the
the
several people on the
small
10 15 20 person facebook team including
their founding cto blaine cook
i started becoming friendly with kevin
rose
who was the founder of digg.com who's
now very big in web 3 with moon birds
i
i started getting in the mix i started
reading techcrunch
um and i was like oh man there's like
this whole world
and then blaine cook called me and said
i'm leaving twitter
and i'm really not happy
and want to just sell all my shares just
wanna wipe my hands of it
and and i know that you're a big
believer gary and you've been really
nice to me and i think you you get it
bigger than just the way the nerds and i
see it and would you like to buy some of
my equity and i said yes sir first i
spent like five minutes trying to talk
him out of it
but then i bought it so it was my first
transaction ever
i had to find a
law firm in new jersey
um i found one the junior guy that was
ascending to partner was a man by the
name of mark yudkin
he now is the ceo and my general counsel
my whole world
so from the first investment i ever made
uh several months later randy zuckerberg
called me said um mark and i wanted to
reach out our parents are sure are
selling
um some of our their stock because they
want to buy a house in california to be
buy coastal to be near us would you like
to buy facebook stock i said yes
uh that was the biggest check i've ever
written um that was a six figure check
it wiped pretty much all my savings out
and then finally and by the way that's
ironically this is crazy this is
actually their certificates from tumblr
and twitter of my investments then
finally in that same year
david carp and i became friendly he came
to the wine library and i said david i
really want to invest in tumblr i think
you're the next big thing and
the first three companies i invested in
in my entire life as an investor were
facebook twitter and tumblr tumblr sold
for a billion dollars to yahoo a couple
years later facebook and twitter
obviously went ipo i've never sold a
share of facebook
since the day i invested
um almost 15 years ago and um i sold
some twitter but still hold the majority
of that holdings from then and um
and then you know a year or two later i
started to make business content not
wine content in 2009
i'd really established myself with a
book called crush it about social media
and now in 2009 10 i was really part of
that silicon valley web 2 thing and away
i went can i ask you and this i mean
this no you put yourself in those
positions but like i had chris sacker on
the show and he said i may be lucky but
it wasn't by accident
can i ask when you look back to the
first investments and when you actually
think on the career how much of a role
do you think luck plays
luck plays a role
in everything if you're willing to go
there so for example i was born in the
ussr
and
communist russia from 1917 to 1991
basically did not let people leave the
country
a lot of people don't know this but
communist ussr was a jail unlike
iran
more like north korea
you were not allowed to leave the
country
and so
i
was born in 1975 in 1971 or two there
was a political event that happened
where some russians tried to hijack a
plane and go to sweden to escape the
country it became a brouhaha
internationally and russia tweaked its
rules and allowed people who were jewish
to go to israel
and that's how they kind of like calmed
the geopolitical storm
i am jewish i was born in 1975 and in
1978 we won a lotto that a couple
hundred thousand people won and was able
to leave the soviet union and i grew up
in america as an entrepreneur
i would argue that my entire life is
luck in that scenario because otherwise
i would have
had i not been jewish or had that
situation not happened i would have
probably come to america maybe when the
berlin wall fell in 1991 and i would be
a totally different human being
so
that is luck me
working hard
staying curious staying up late at night
and not playing video games but reading
the internet finding out about social
media flying to london to go to future
of web apps to learn going to south by
southwest to texas to learn
putting myself in a position to meet the
companies that i personally thought were
good facebook and twitter and tumblr
putting in the hours providing value to
those people so that i became a friend
not just somebody who's
hanging around
thinking working trying
feels less luck
but
when people use luck or talk about
timing and things that nature of course
i could have been born in the 20s my
parents could have never met and i've
never been a bit of a human being
everybody is lucky and nobody is lucky
it just depends on deciding what you
want to say and do
but as far as like the strategy
i feel incredibly comfortable in saying
saving my money in my 20s
and then deciding to spend all of it in
a one-year period on facebook twitter
and tumblr
based on
at that point 10 years of very hard work
diligence
of saving and not wasting my money
and looking for the opportunity to
strike
doesn't feel
as
oriented towards luck as it does towards
being thoughtful with the gifts i was
given which could be luck and this is
the point of it all
now i've listened to pretty much every
uh episode that i could find um which
means i've done a lot of walking over
the last few days of your interviews and
i wanted to really ask questions that
other people haven't done um and so
let's just start with a tough one which
was
difficult times bring about very
important lessons what's the most
difficult but valuable lesson that
you've learned
the most difficult lesson was when me
and my dad started to have friction in
my late 20s early 30s
from 22 to 29 i didn't even question why
my dad wasn't paying me much even though
i blew up his business
i didn't question why my dad wasn't
interested in giving me some equity even
though i blew up his business
and just for everybody who's listening
who doesn't know anything about my story
my dad had a business doing 3.8 million
in revenue and in a seven year window i
took it to 60 million
and i changed the course of my father's
financial life and my mother's financial
life yet i was never getting paid 100
000 a year and owned nothing
and i was the operator
and so
when i kind of got to like an age where
i felt like i was growing up and
thinking about like maybe i should buy a
house or an apartment maybe you know
because i was blindly like i'm going to
help my parents
so when i started asking questions the
answers were not of
the kind that i was hoping for
how did you take that is it i mean i
took it very poorly it was very
difficult you know you sit there and
you're like i'm you know the reason i
was willing to do what i did was because
my father built the base
but i was sitting there and said i've
been bleeding seven days a week the last
eight years
i've like the math is the math like this
is how much it did before i took over
look what's happened everything's
different
um everyone's life is better my
brother's life is better my sister's
life is better my parents life is better
my life is fine but like i'm definitely
not getting my fair shake
i assumed the conversation was going to
be really easy
aren't i the 50 50 partner at least i'm
more than
20x the company and the answers were no
the answers were
you'll get it when i die i'm like well
you're you've got good genes and you're
only 22 years older than me i'm not sure
i want to inherit this business when i'm
70.
um
and
and it was a challenge now i was
empathetic
which helps i underst i could understand
where my father was coming from he was
an immigrant land not in startup land
not in america land he was old country
he was like it's the family business and
when the dad dies the son takes over the
daughter and like and so i understood
but it was very very challenging not to
mention that he was in charge of
building the new store he was the
general contractor of this new store
which was
two years behind and five times over
budget so on top of everything else i'm
frustrated with him because i don't
think he's delivering the promise that
i'm delivering and that's putting a lot
of pressure on me when you're going over
budget that much and you're trying to
pay for [ __ ] you're scared
so it was a very trying time that i
don't talk about often and i'm only
doing this because i feel like you put
in so many hours that i i feel compelled
plus i don't do it because i don't want
to paint the wrong picture my dad's the
best it was just what it was
and so those were long nights that was
the first time
and what i learned from it was what i
preach which is
[ __ ] money
business doesn't mean [ __ ]
your family
life
happiness and i am proud to say i was
the bigger man that i feel like i had
plenty of opportunities to turn it into
a much more contentious negative
situation and instead what i did was i
built infrastructure around myself
made myself capable of moving on at some
point without detrimenting the business
my father
also
would tell you if he was on he'd be like
cool that's gary's problem let me tell
you what my problem was i came to
america and had nothing i built this
business
yes my son came and crushed it
but yes i was maybe winning financially
more than he was but i had lost my
identity i went from being sasha the man
at shoppers discount liquors and wine
library to the people i've been doing
business with for 20 years wouldn't even
return my call because everyone knew
gary was running [ __ ] and gary was the
guy and i'm and i'm
my dad's only 22 years older than me so
when i'm the man at 24 and i was
my dad was 46 to remind everybody
listening i'm 46 right now so my 46 year
old father who's an alpha
who's prideful as they come
is now walking around
and he would always use this russian
term and it would translate to a senator
with an empty briefcase and what that
meant in russia talk was in that
briefcase it was cash to get [ __ ] done
he was a senator
yeah he owns it but he has an empty
briefcase and nobody's [ __ ] talking
to him and it killed him inside so
luckily for us which is why i can talk
about it openly there was a moment there
where i think he wanted to be the man
again
and i needed to build something for
myself my brother was 11 years younger
coming out of school
and 2009 just kind of really worked out
and at 34 years old i started
vaynermedia with no money
we started the company in buddy media's
conference room which i'm sure you know
because you've listened to another
interviews
and i'm very proud of what we built from
zero and scratch with no cash and um
did that experience impact how you think
about bringing up encouraging your
children today the words you use how you
incentivize them you know what's funny i
i yes but more of how i encourage all of
you
you know what i know about my kids even
at this age is they're still forming who
they are
but
you know
there's a there's a high propensity that
my children are not going to be
as
interested in being a pure i don't think
my children are purebred entrepreneurs
the way i was they're different and
that's amazing i want people to be who
they are i don't want them to be like me
so
i think it's impacting more of how i'm
teaching the world more so than my own
children because my children are
individual people that have their thing
i think i'm speaking from a perspective
of experience within an arena
that resonates with a lot of people and
that's why i think i'm such a prolific
content creator
because i'd like people to win because i
think people winning doesn't come out of
my winning
it's a nice feeling i think the world
doesn't have enough people who are
deploying good into it and i'm
passionate about that
when i listen to so many of your shows
and when i listen to you now the thing i
get is like security the wisdom comes
through and the assuredness comes
through and funny it never sounds that
you have self-doubt or insecurity when i
was listening and i was just intrigued
what everyone's insecure and doubtful of
themselves in some way how yeah
yeah i love that question i'm
the reason you see that is that when i
stay in the arena of business there is
something pretty crazy i am a little
scared thank god kobe bryant and
some of the you know i don't want to
bring up jordan and tom brady because i
hate them so much as jets and knicks
fans but thank god there's some of these
athletes out there
that i can look at and be like uh-huh
that like when i tell
you for anybody who loves kobe bryant i
think there's a pretty good
understanding including a documentary i
saw this week that talked about when he
was oh it was actually a book i read
which is rare for me but i read a book
about the 90 nix the 90s here on new
york knicks and they there's a little
piece they talk about kobe coming in
working out and they talked about him
being 17 18 and feeling like he was 48
with no doubt
and that that's who i've been as an
entrepreneur no question
to answer your question directly i have
many parts of my life where i doubt i
had a lot of doubt as like a teenager
and in my 20s around like asking girls
out my my confidence level in like
girlfriend boyfriend like school stuff
wasn't at the same level as business i
have this one's a wild one i have
incredible fear of reading out loud
because i'm terrible at reading
literally at the passover table reading
passages
frightens me amongst my family but i can
go give a improv keynote
to seven billion people on earth right
now if there was a stage for the entire
world literally if tomorrow they're like
there's this new stage and it's
simulcast to every person on earth and
you can submit for slots and you get a
to give a 15-minute keynote to the world
i would literally submit for a keynote
immediately
if i had to do it right now harry if
you're like actually gary i'm a genie
from the future and i can do that if i
snap my fingers you will have to be on
stage right now and every person on
earth is listening to you talk i would
do it right now
yet
reading
a children's book
to every to you
and andrew right now in my office would
shut would scare me
so i've been securities i'm a human
being but i have none when it comes to
being an entrepreneur and i'm not
kidding
like
i'm not kidding i'm really not scared
has that ever got you in trouble it's
got me in trouble when i've not it has
it hasn't gotten me in trouble because
my lack of fear is also balanced with
extraordinary
levels of empathy and compassion to the
other parties involved in my behaviors
the reason the reason i was such a class
clown and disrupter in class but adored
by my teachers was i knew how to walk
the fine line of not disrespecting them
while still doing my shenanigans
because she said about speaking to the
world in one sitting
there's public gary and there's private
gary or there's public harry and there's
private harry especially for me i
struggle with this identity friction
between the two
do you have the identity chasm between
what the world sees and who you actually
are when you're sitting with your kids
in them
i
am pretty much what you get somebody so
who said that to me just now oh i was
just talking to a gentleman who worked
for us for four years
four hours ago four hours ago it was an
exit
the way you dream it up when you're the
kind of entrepreneur i am this was
purely like i love you i thank you and
i'm here for you and that person's
saying i love you thank you it was
perfect i can't even say anything bad in
four years this was a better financial
bigger opportunity
i'm about to hang out because hey
and we didn't interact a lot i did
interview him four years ago and hired
him but we didn't interact a lot after
he goes
um
could you say something i'm like of
course
what what's up he said um
you know you've gotten really popular
and known since i've worked here he goes
i'm probably asked 13 times a day and i
only know like 15 people uh this is his
whole shtick of
what's gary really like
and he goes it's really cool to tell
those people whether they're cynical or
their major fans
that he's exactly what you see
i am who i am in the context
professionally
behind the scenes with my team at a
vayner that you see
to your point of like who am i as like a
brother as a son
in my personal life
i'm contextually who i am there but
obviously
that's a different human being but it's
not like i'm a dick face or i'm reserved
i'm high energy i'm kind
i'm pumped
it just formulates differently it's like
let's go to the park or let's watch tv
and by the way on the flip side
you know
depth is really just more of like
sometimes it's not watch tv or like go
to the park it's actually just sitting
and talking i love doing that um but you
know it's very easy for me to reconcile
the public output of content versus the
things i want to keep private and it's
very important for me that my personal
life is extremely private like extremely
private i don't share anything about it
what else you said about kind of
becoming very big as you are now
when you started becoming very big
was ego management a challenge it's
really hard so i mean the world wants
you and you're like
i
don't believe in my hype
which is what allows me to not believe
in the hate thrown towards me
which is the natural
thing that happens when you get
popularity and success as well so it was
actually very easy for me harry like it
was funny i was with my college friends
who i haven't been able to spend a lot
of time with since i left because i've
been working every minute everyone's
around the country and they were at vcon
and
it was just so awesome like they were so
pumped
and all of them these are like 46 to 48
year old men
every one of them i know and these are
thuggy like my friends from college are
from the hood for lack of a better word
they were all one by one were really
nice and emotional with me like teary
moments one by one there was about five
of them there
different times one called after the
event two during there one at night
during your one in the breakfast
they just like like it's really cool
that you are literally literally
actually actually
exactly the same
and for me it was like very flattering
but like very easy and i'll tell you why
this is all dna
all that money and fame do harry
is exposes who you actually are
it just accelerates your truth
you know to me what are you doing like
who you actually are i might well if you
don't like who you yeah like if you
don't look yeah
if you don't like who yeah i mean that's
what do you think why do you i mean
think about my content my content is far
more
therapy
than it is
business
hbs
this is all about self-esteem
harry this is all about self-esteem and
one of the reasons i tell everybody
things i try both things i'm like you
have like don't like i try
i try to get people to self-love
themselves for like just asking them
what's the alternative or i love saying
things remember if you think you suck
somebody put that in your head
like you didn't come out of the womb and
be like i suck
you think you suck because your mom told
you you suck you think you suck because
your dad told you you suck like that's
and then i try to get people to like
reconcile that and then i try to remind
them that everybody else sucks too so
why are you beating yourself up self
love is i'm almost using business as a
disguise to try to help people be
happier
what would you advise me i get a ton of
dms comments
i hate you you're a prick what you don't
deserve it you're young you're rich
whatever and like horrible matches some
death threats even in the past like and
it really upsets me like i cry i will be
very sad what would you advise me
well there's a couple things first i
would ask you is how much if any of it
resonates with you as truth
not at all they don't know me there's
random people
then you then you're really in a good
place like for me one of the things i've
liked about
pushback hate negativity is
i start with humility
is there anything here
can i take two percent out of you know
gary you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's very
hard to take something out of that
but sometimes i will probably be like
i'm really sorry that i trigger this
like and like you could like talk about
well you you think you know everything
i'm like no no i'm passionate and have
conviction which yes
can come across in video and audio that
way but rest assured
i don't know [ __ ] about 99 of [ __ ] in
the world i'm just staying in my very
narrow lane of like sports and wine and
market like this is tiny i don't know
anything about a million things that's
why i don't talk about brain surgery so
i don't talk about meditation that's why
i don't talk about a million things
so there's that
so first i start with humility then i
start with compassion harry if somebody
actually i know you've heard this in my
content because i talk about it all the
time
i do think
having some compassion for those people
bro it sucks to live a life where you
actually want to tear someone else down
it means you're really unhappy
and you should just be happy that your
life isn't about sitting around finding
someone on youtube or twitter or
instagram and sending them a nasty dm
i really go with empathy
and like accountability i'm like is
there anything right are they right am i
getting too high on my own supply b man
i really feel bad
that this is what they want to spend
their time on
c
deep breath reset like there's 99 of the
people 86 percent of people that are
thrilled and it's going well let me
focus on consuming positivity one of the
biggest things that drives me today
is that the world speaks about so much
negativity that i feel a requirement to
talk about positivity because what one
consumes is who they become
and
i'm very proud of my practical
optimistic framework i'm optimistic but
i'm not delusional and i'm not creating
foofy foofy 8th place trophies it's like
hey this is real [ __ ] but we can do this
nicely and i i beat that drum very
aggressively you said about where you
spend time and i'm using this for just
pure therapy session now um how do you
not lose an inch on performance
work-wise but also a great brother or a
great father how do you not listen
easy easy because i don't judge within
short time frames
expand what do you mean this is gonna
really you're gonna like this one the
reason i don't struggle by losing my
edge or being a killer by allocating
time to personal endeavors time with
family or escapism
is because i don't judge my success
or giving up an inch
in the time frame of a week
a month
or a year
i am incredibly ambitious but the frame
of timing
that i put my hopes and wants and dreams
of my accomplishments
is for the length of my life
not
this month
so if the next four days i don't want to
do anything it's just four days in a 99
year life
can i is that is that the result though
of many years of success and finances
being built up were you the same
it's the reverse
listen back to the interview how the
hell do you think i ever did the thing i
did in the first place for my parents i
gave up my 20s for them
because at 22 at 22 i was like i'm gonna
do this for eight years i used to think
about 30 a lot i'm gonna do this for
eight years just give it to my folks not
give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it i'll figure it out after because
i've got 30 to 99.
did you find it hard having to grow up
so much faster than everyone else
i didn't know the difference i didn't
know that i was growing up faster i
didn't realize that my dad was gone all
the time and thus i was the oldest son
from the old country and i was the
father figure to my sister and brother i
didn't realize that i was 14 and working
14 hours a day and that's probably not
normal we were such immigrants in our
cocoon i just didn't even know
and i also grew up in blue-collar like i
didn't grow up like all my friends
worked at amp making six bucks an hour i
grew up in i didn't grow up in affluence
so me working a lot it wasn't like my
friends were going to sleepaway camp or
like ibiza or the hamptons i everybody
else was kind of doing either sitting at
home and being a good student or working
at [ __ ] mcdonald's you know what i
mean so
i wasn't in an environment where i felt
like it was i mean i was the most
extreme of everybody but i also loved it
i loved being a business person
that realization causes you to make a
decision you said before that changing
your mind is the strength how do you
know when to give up on something versus
when to persist and [ __ ] man
love that question i like giving up on
something when
i no longer like it regardless of the
financial outcome
i just i try to capitalize against being
content satisfied and happy
not maximizing the financial aspect of
the situation at hand does everything
happen and that and that and that i'll
answer that one in a minute and that is
the reverse of what people think to your
question earlier most people think this
mindset and who i am
comes because i have money
back to my college friends
i have money because i had the mindset
when i had no money
it's the reverse
i knew that i was happy at 25 making 48
000 a year buying nothing
so i could be happy forever so who gives
a [ __ ] because making a million bucks
wasn't going to be my happiness radar
and yes everything has a price
there's not a everything does have a
price because
the reality is
well it's funny game like you know it's
funny as i'm answering how i'm thinking
about this i'll give you an example
i'm answering yes everything has a price
because in reality i believe that but i
just thought of something if somebody
came to me and said i will give you
100 billion dollars in cash
but you can never work again
you must fully retire
meaning the cliche thing must go on a
beach
in a very nice place
and actually do nothing besides drink
beers walk on the beach look at the
sunset
fish we'll give you fishing which i like
kind of fun here and there right
i
would not take that
i would not take that
that would break my soul i would die you
know how sometimes people you know this
is going to land for you and andrews in
the background here you know when you
see like an 8 year old person lose their
spouse and they die like a week later
and they're like grandpa died of a
broken heart he couldn't live without
grandma but he was perfectly fine a week
before
there's a part of me that actually
believes that i have that with work i
just i've said this often and means
you've heard it because you consumed a
lot
it is my great hobby
whatever anybody loves the most
everybody listening whatever you love
the most skiing sailing fishing
basketball uh traveling uh frisbee
beard
making um watching movies whatever it is
whatev like everyone listening and
watching stop tell me the number one
thing you like more than anything in the
world
for me that is being an entrepreneur
i want to do three quick quick fire
questions they're under a minute each so
we'll get it done first one is
what have you recently changed your mind
on gary
well that's a great question what if i
reason i changed my mind on how big of a
platform facebook is
one of the coolest things for me right
now is that i'm back into being obsessed
with content on facebook because the
math
of supply and demand of attention on it
has flipped aggressively with ios 14
update and everybody kind of going away
from it spending ads but yet still
there's a lot of people consuming it so
the most recent thing is very narrow it
is my content strategy on facebook
i mean there's an episode in that to be
fair um what's the greatest
accomplishment of your life in your mind
that i am
exceedingly liked by the far majority of
people i've ever interacted with
final one for you we do this in five
years time why do you want garyvee to be
then
hopefully in the same exact spot he is
right now which is not anxious about the
health and well-being of anybody that he
loves meaning nobody is terminally ill
and
doing what he wants to do every day
professionally
whether that's the mundane i'm sorry to
like i know you're going for the big
clothes but i just want everybody to
hear this
me doing what i want to do every day
means i'm doing plenty of things every
day i don't want to be doing in the
micro
right there's a the next meeting the
this this fire but in the macro i'm
playing the game i'm the captain of this
ship and on sunny days i get to enjoy it
and when the storm hits and our boat
might tip over i've got to have my hands
on the wheel and i've got to fix it
that's where i want to be forever gary
this has been amazing you are a hero i
so appreciate the time and honestly
thank you so much stay safe
[Music]